dis donc madame la ministre après un
début de quinquennat exécuté à marche
forcée nous constatons tous ici un net
ralentissement de la marche depuis le 15
janvier
le temps législatif est figé et on ne
compte plus les projets de lois reporter
et les réformes suspendus aux
conclusions du grand débat national
plus grave sans doute encore le travail
parlementaire est désormais balayé d'un
revers de manche par votre gouvernement
ainsi le 11 décembre dernier le sénat a
voté à une très large majorité une
proposition de loi portée par notre
collègue françoise gatel rapportés par
agnès canayer proposition de loi qui
visait à apporter de la souplesse au
fonctionnement et à l'organisation des
communes nouvelles qui rappelons le
concerne 2 millions près de deux
millions et demi de français dans 757 55
communes nouvelles vous avez en tout cas
le gouvernement avait soutenu cette
démarche qui est particulièrement
attendu et notamment dans mon
département de maine et loire
hélas nous apprenons cette semaine que
l'examen de ce texte à l'assemblée
nationale qui était inscrit dans
l'agenda de l'assemblée nationale a été
reportée sine aidiez ce qui va à
l'encontre de votre à ganges engagement
madame la ministre
quelles garanties pouvaient pouvez vous
nous apportez pour que ce report ne soit
pas purement et simplement un d'amande
où la parole est à madame jacqueline
gourault au ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur vous avez rappelé l'importance
des communes nouvelles qui je le
rappelle ont été créées par la loi de
2010 et réformer en 2015 par le député
jacques pélissard cette politique est un
grand succès puisque aujourd'hui 2500
huit communes se sont regroupés pour
créer sept cent soixante quatorze
communes nouvelles
on peut féliciter d'égypte ailleurs ne
serait-ce qu'en 2019 il y en a encore eu
239 en conséquence d'ailleurs le nombre
de communes et d'aujourd'hui de 34 1970
pour être très précise alors on sait
monsieur le sénateur que cette politique
a beaucoup de succès particulièrement
dans l'ouest de la france et notamment
dans le maine-et-loire que vous
représentez ici au sénat mais aussi dans
la manche
dans le calvados et dans l'eure pour
citer ceux qui arrivent en tête
vous me parlez alors bien sûr je ne
parle pas de l'accompagnement qui avait
été voté aussi financier etc
la proposition de loi adoptée
effectivement par votre haute assemblée
en décembre vise en ce sens à faciliter
le développement des communes nouvelles
et améliorées surtout les périodes
transitoires notamment ceux qui
concernent la composition des conseils
municipaux
hier la deuxième période ce texte a été
reçue très positivement
il a été soutenu par le gouvernement
il est aujourd'hui bien sûr nécessaire
de d'envisager sa lecture mais il est
envisagé bien sûr à la lumière des
concertations menées actuellement avec
les maires dans le cadre du grand débat
à ce stade il a donc été décidé de
différer son examen monsieur
le sénateur et il ne faut pas toujours
voir le mal quelque part ses pieds noirs
pour 39 secondes
madame la ministre on reproche souvent
au parlement sa lenteur dans la
confection de la loi mais aujourd'hui
c'est le gouvernement qui bloque selon
le gouvernement qui ne veut pas
comprendre qu'il ya urgence à légiférer
sur ce texte notamment à la proche des
futures élections municipales j'entends
bien à votre volonté affichée d'être à
l'écouté je m'en félicite
c'est un changement notable peut-être
pourriez-vous aller jusqu'à entendre la
volonté des parlementaires qui
travaillent et qu'ils se saisissent des
attentes des élus locaux en étroite
collaboration d'ailleurs avec
l'association des maires de france
pourriez peut-être pourriez-vous
collectivement dans votre gouvernement
consacré un peu moins de temps à
l'animation du show médiatique de votre
mentor et davantage à une meilleure
considération du travail des élus
nationaux
peut-être pourriez-vous peut-être
pourriez-vous enfin tout simplement
respecter vos engagements par rapport
aux élus que nous sommes
[Applaudissements]